let's talk about media credibility in
this unique moment in time with Ben
Shapiro he's the editor in chief of the
Daily wire been great to see you good to
see you too you bargain in the past the
media should not go around pointing out
how abnormal these circumstances are
what why is that well I mean I think
that it sort of depends like this stuff
over this weekend was not particularly
normal so it's hard for me to argue the
media shouldn't be saying that you know
the president is acting in non normal
fashion
with regard to the Russian investigation
that said I think that because the media
have been saying not normal so often for
so long for over a year for two years at
this point and a certain point it
becomes the boy who cried wolf even when
something is not normal as it has been
this weekend I think there are a lot of
folks who go well that's just the media
spouting off how are we supposed to
trust them after two years of them
saying that everything the man does
isn't normal isn't that partly because
there's been a decade-long movement on
the right to discredit the media well
before President Trump came along yeah I
would be surprised if it's just a decade
I mean I think they're decades yeah you
know on the right for as long as I've
been alive there's been a lot of
questions about media objectivity and I
don't think that those questions are
ill-founded I think this is why as I've
been saying it's really incumbent on the
media to do as much reporting of the
facts as possible and leave a lot of the
hyperbole out of it I know that's really
difficult at a time when you know the
hyperbole seems to not only get ratings
but also to to jog people's kind of
amygdalas but the fact is that the more
the more the media underplays I think
the better they will do in terms of
people trusting them because at this
time what's happening right now is
everything's breaking down to tribal
affinity President Trump says fake news
a lot of his people say okay well if the
president says it the media are fake on
a lot of topics or at least they are
biased on a lot of topics so why
wouldn't they be biased here as well the
media sort need to bend over backwards
to prove that they aren't biased
especially in cases like the Russia
investigation again I think that what
the president's done this weekend is not
normal I think that if the president
were to fire Robert Mahler it would
precipitate some really devastating
politics in the country for sure and it
should but I think that it's it's
important that the media you know hold
their fire up till the point where
something really terrible has happened
I'm sorry but the firing of Andy McCabe
for example on Friday that was
recommended by the OPR that's that's not
something that is that is wildly out of
bounds what is out of bounds obviously
is the president talking about firing
Muller or if he would actually fire
Muller where do you see them
egregious media bias right now well over
the last three weeks obviously the
coverage of the gun debate has been
absolutely egregious and I don't want to
single out your network but CNN it's
been pretty bad on this from a
conservative perspective the the idea
that when there's a mass shooting that
the media feel the necessity to put on
TV not only survivors but specific
survivors that there's a certain subset
of survivors who make it on TV a lot a
lot and there are certain other
survivors who don't and that they
decided to single out certain events and
not other events in order to make a
particular case or they allow certain
people to go on TV and suggest that
folks like Dana lash or people at the
NRA are evil don't care they're
terrorists and there's no pushback from
the anchors you know this sort of thing
makes a lot of people on the right feel
that the media are really using this as
an opportunity to push gun control
rather than objectively covering you
know the legislative efforts that are
going on in Washington DC so your view
is there should be 50/50 even if most of
the students are urging gun control
measures you want it to be 50/50 or no I
think adding 80/20 would be fine if omit
anything but 95 5 would probably be a
good thing and I think that it's also
pretty obvious that listen everybody
this is my opinion about journalism
everybody in journalism has their own
political views we all vote obviously or
at least most of us do and it's it's not
a pleasant thing when people in the
media pretend their political views are
not influencing their coverage when it's
so obvious that those political views
clearly are influencing their coverage
but if the political just to want fewer
gun deaths that's not political well
obviously it's not political to want
fewer gun deaths nobody wants more gun
deaths I think that what is political is
allowing certain people to go on TV and
without any sort of follow-up question
say things like the political enemies
don't care about human lives like I
remember CNN got very upset when Dana
lash said at CPAC that people in the
media reporters may challenge something
that's it's not a network-wide thing
well okay but reporters need to
challenge I mean it but again the
reporters are the representatives of
their network I mean when I tuned in and
there's a reporter on CNN and the CNN
insignia is in the bottom corner of the
crawl there's nothing I can do as an
observer but say okay well CNN may have
a bias here especially if that bias all
runs in one direction it's not like some
of the members of CNN are pushing a
particular agenda until are pushing
another agenda it's there's always if
there is a bias it is universally to one
side and that's what people on the
writers say
see the agenda that's being pushed is
done controlled by interviewing students
who are scared to go back to school is
that is that how you perceive it no I
mean I think that the agenda being
pushed is gun control if there again is
no pushback on questions that would be
asked to any other guests I think the
tragedy is obviously a terrible thing
but it doesn't necessarily confer
expertise and that's one of the big
problems here you're very popular Bend
you want to grab that yeah exactly
goodness
it happens to all of us I ask you though
you know you your website The Daily wire
a lot of other conservative media sites
that have criticism of the press I
sometimes worry you all are trying to
tear things down as opposed to make them
better it's one thing to to critique and
want journalism to be better but
sometimes I feel like you're just trying
to get rid of journalism altogether
maybe questioning the motive I don't
think is a useful thing if you can point
out to me where the critique is wrong I
think that's one thing if the suggestion
is that the critique is invalid because
the motive is invalid
that's another so again I think that if
you don't like the motive then ignore
the motive and take the critique yes
insofar as it's effective right we all
have motives but but the fact is listen
I don't want CNN to disappear I don't
want the New York Times to disappear
don't want the Washington posta
disappear I want them to do what they
are say what they say they are supposed
to be doing I want them to perform
objective journalism if that's what they
say they're gonna do and opinion
journalism if they want to say that
their opinion journalist that's fine my
problem is when this is why my critique
of for example the New York Times op-ed
page is far less than my critique of the
New York Times objective journalism
there's a difference between op-ed and
journalism it's why my critique of MSNBC
sometimes is a lot less strident I think
than my critique of CNN because CNN
purports to be objective MSNBC really
does not purport to be objective in the
same way part of me thinks that you and
your colleagues of the daily wire should
try to get jobs then at the New York
Times if you don't like the coverage try
to be a part of the solution as opposed
to complaining about it I mean I don't
know would you hire me I I really doubt
that and not only that as a guest for
many months I was wondering you know the
deli wires been growing your profile has
been blowing up there was talk about you
may be taking over Glenn Beck's the
blaze can you tell us if that's true and
where you see your media company going
in the future
I mean all I can say about that is we're
always looking for opportunities to grow
and we are very much fans of what Glenn
does any opportunity we have to work
with Glenn like a lot of other folks who
are happy to take there are interesting
interesting teas all right
great to see you thanks for coming on
the program thanks so much